Good to be back
live. There's uh network maintenance
today and
uh lots of cutouts on this, but it's
probably still uh it's probably fine
now.
We are seeing dropped frames on
here. Let me see if that's
stable. I just dropped a few. Okay.
Well, hopefully it's fine. We'll see
very quickly if it's not.
Um I'm thinking we should
probably try to match the old perf on
this real quick.
Yeah, we should probably do
that just because
like this not working is bothering
me. First of all, it's map size
31. Max size didn't
specified. Map size. So, max size
doesn't get specified.
And then 512
m. Uh, we need more than
that. I think you need 1024
minimum and the map say
need to specify max size I
suppose.
Okay, now this is the one that didn't
work. I think it was
go. So we see how this trains. Then we
try with the old
hypers. We go from there.
and make sure reream
shows. So, we were able to get like 60
to 80 on this task, I'm pretty
sure. So, I want to make sure that I
didn't either break something in the end
or in the
trainer. It's completely different
hypers. So,
Okay, we will
try most of these to start
lambda. Uh, we don't do that
anymore. We don't do this. Well, maybe
this is
better? This is the only end I'm a bit
worried about because we're using this
actively for curriculum stuff.
Um, okay. So, the fact that this just
like
doesn't do
anything is concerning.
I think what I'm going to do is I'm
going to leave the
params the way I had them like this and
then we're going to go see if we can
figure out the experience buffer
thing. That's going to be a pain, but
we'll have to figure it
out.
Okay, so this is what I was trying to do
last night, but I just got too tired.
Um, I think we can probably figure this
out if we make that the goal to figure
this out today.
you need to have on policy rows
be a multiple of uh the free index or
whatever. Right? The big issue here was
this less than
sign. So this should be less than equals
but it doesn't train when you have less
than equals.
Um, the issue is that there are a bunch
of trajectory
segments and as you collect data, you
fill up trajectory
segments, but you need a way to figure
out when you're
done when you're done collecting
data. I'm trying to think like what
would be a good stable replacement for
this check
here
because this is not doing it.
to I'm kind of tempted to revert back to
like my old back impulse check or
whatever.
So just collect as many steps as you
need in the
batch and then we just throw errors if
that doesn't work
out. It's probably the best way of doing
it. Let me see how we used to do this.
Pointer greater than equal batch
size.
We don't get any indexing bugs from
this. Apparently not.
16? I think this was 16 before, wasn't
it?
There should be a way to break this
though. Like if I just do a 64, this
should just break,
I Okay, I don't know what's going on
today with um with the internet. It
seems like this is reream because I go
and I check speed test and it
immediately works. So, I don't know if
this is unstable reream server today or
what, but I'm just going to work around
it as best I can for now. And if it
keeps happening, then we'll figure
something out
tomorrow. But I want to make sure we
finish this
524. Okay, this is perfectly 8192
agents, right?
So it would make sense to have
4K forward pass batch size with this,
right? And we'll just see if that works.
So num ms here should be
16. Also, wouldn't this be like way
better if I just
1.5 million step per second
training. A lot of miscellaneous
overhead.
We should probably make sure that we're
not um slower because of the horizon as
well.
seems we are able to train a good
policy. Okay.
before. Now let's see if there is any
perf overhead with the
BP4 as well.
Now there is not any perf penalty with a
longer horizon. We are very well set up
in fact right
there. Possibly mini batch size has to
go up come to think of it
now. And possibly mini batch size has to
go
up. I think we'll have to test. That
one's like potentially a lot more of a
disruptive change.
fine. Can I just delete all this and
have it work?
Why is this
not this does not show up here? I guess
it's not
go. Score is still
fine.
Matches 1.8 mills per second. Rins quite
nicely.
about we'll see if we actually get logs
back from this. That's the main